la troisième fête de l'internet avec
comme principes essentiels faire
partager à tous les français les joies
de surfer sur le réseau mondial
aujourd'hui nous sommes près de 5
millions à utiliser le web à disposition
des internautes et des consommateurs que
nous sommes toutes sortes de sites
permettant d'acheter moins cher patrice
pollet jean louis ousset wr grâce à
internet on peut réaliser son rêve sans
se ruiner
cette société s'il fait dans l'oise et
le numéro un français des vols et des
séjours à prix réduit ici 1500 clients
par jour passe comment tous les produits
présentés sont à des prix cassés voulais
simplement vous confirmer cette
réservation au tarif de 9 110 francs au
lieu de 1470 franc aux premières cialis
l'ensemble des invendus de la profession
que ce soit des hôtels des séjours des
avions c'est qu'on n'y trouve que des
bonnes affaires avec des réduction
minimale de 30 à 40%
si vous êtes intéressés vous pouvez
retrouver dire plus sympathique
on peut aussi commander grâce à sa
webcam ensuite plusieurs possibilités
sont offertes payer à distance avec sa
carte bancaire ou pour ceux qui auraient
des craintes communiqué les numéros de
cin carte par fax ou par téléphone
pour choisir une voiture un piano ou un
aspirateur plus besoin de se déplacer
c'est sur internet et on peut faire des
économies
ce grand bazar virtuel propose cent
mille objets un catalogue impressionnant
où tout est vendu aux enchères sur les
voitures pour espérer jusqu'à 10 jusqu'à
20% de réduction par rapport à l'argus
vous n'avez pas besoin réellement des
espaces pour exister vous les besoins de
stands pour montrer votre objet comme
les professionnels les particuliers
peuvent espérer faire des affaires grâce
à l'accès direct à leurs actions sur
internet acheter vendre ont pu suivre
les cours de la bourse
toute la journée sans internet je me
demande si je serai allé sur sur la
bourse
parce qu'on a une richesse
d'informations très très immédiates 1
c'est la fête sur internet en cliquant
bien on peut trouver son bonheur